you're working an hour a day on the
property business but the property
business is making more than the
plumbing business how many hours are you
working on the plumbing business 60
hours a week a lot of people said it
would never work in car you know it's C
the wheel so there's no reason why it
shouldn't work I got you know two
properties buffed up until the new year
just taking on the third now how's life
changed then over the last s 6 12 months
just got
Mentor well welcome Ian Thomas from
charell properties the way from Sunny
Wales congratulations on your success I
wanted really in this interview to pick
your brains on how you've accumulated
Financial Freedom over the last how many
months when did you start eight months
in the last eight months specifically in
Wales because I know most of your
properties are in or around Cardiff area
and um hopefully be able to pass on some
golden nuggets and we give people that
are starting out from a a pretty much
standing start be able to emulate what
you've done so why don't you start from
the beginning what made you get into
property in the first first place um
just looking for something a little bit
more passive um I'm self-employed plar
was quite um sort of time intensive if
I'm not in work I'm not earning money
yeah um you know I am the business
basically so I'm just looking for
something where I can invest in um you
know and property seems to be the number
one thing yeah to to sort of get any
passive income and gain sort of
generation generational wealth I'm
seeing more of more more trades people
as well getting into the property
investment property entrepreneur side of
things because they're out all day you
know fixing up
properties understand the bricks and
morar side of it but being an
entrepreneur on on the property side of
things you know it's it's a bit of a
transition so now then you've got how
many how many properties uh so three at
the moment just taking on a fourth uh so
three of those are going to be in
Cardiff and one's in bath they all rent
the service accomodations nice and
that's enabled your wife to quit her job
yeah so she's just worked her last shift
on Friday just gone another big
milestone for us so she's going to come
on board and help me out now hopefully
and the profit as well that you're
making for each property is quite
substantial right you're making like
about a grand a month yeah per property
which is huge and that's more money than
most landlords make that own the
property so you're controlling the
property but you're you're squeezing the
cash flow and in Cardiff where a lot of
people said it would never work in
Cardiff yeah but you found that it it is
working yeah I said just took the plunge
because like I said it's got everything
in the it's got theat stadiums LS of
construction going on you know it's the
capital of wheel so you there's no
reason why he shouldn't work so I took
the plunge and I got you know two
properties booked up until the new year
uh just taking on the third now
hopefully get a longterm book in in
there and I know you've done a little
bit of deal selling you've sold a few
deals yeah how how long did it take you
to sell your first few deals um it about
a month I was on the phone constantly
just calling and calling being told no
and it was actually a game at at one
point I know two2 was on your Academy he
had 300 NOS so I thought right that's my
target I'm going to get 300 knows yeah
and just and see where we go from there
have have you ever heard of the book
called go for now no I have heard that
phrase before yeah so it's actually a
book generally when you're calling
because because if you want to be
successful from a standing starting
property you're going to get a lot of
rejection right you're going to get
rejection from landlords you're going to
get rejection from Agents from investors
but the idea is who can get the most NOS
so if you're competing with someone like
whoever gets the most NOS generally
speaking will probably get the most
yeses as well so rather than seeing no
there's a real bad thing and be like Oh
been rejected isn't it terrible it's
saying well actually that's part of the
process I need to get NOS in order to
get yeses I need was it would to become
a game I had a chart in the back of my
diary every time they get a no was like
yes another no another no they were
tallying up and I thought yes I'm going
to beat going to beat the 300 yeah and I
got to about I think it about 190 and
then finally got a yes and that yes
happened to be seven Apartments so I
went down put you know done the vi in
put deposits down on all seven and then
I course sold them with the twins
property Twins and Leo um cuz I put the
deposits down obviously was time
sensitive so I thought just Co sour with
people who've done it before me yeah
learn along the way and then we sold
sold five of the apartments I was going
to keep two myself U they ended up
getting delayed by I think it was like
two months time scale didn't suit me at
the time so I ended up handing two back
so another thing is am I WR thinking
that you had an accident and you had
like a a week or two off work yeah that
was when I found the apartment what what
happened so he fell off my motor and fr
should have r back so he forced me to
take some time off work so I still had
the Apprentice work and doing jobs in
the background and I was basically just
sat there full-time in property um and
that's when I had you know more success
I just just calling every single day
yeah and whether it was luck or
coincidence I don't know but that's
that's when I found those I honestly
think that if people worked as hard on
their property business as they do on
their job everybody would be a
millionaire 100% because the amount of
because it's easy as well to quit isn't
it you make a couple of calls get a
couple of rejections say a this isn't
really working but actually imagine if
you hired somebody to be a full-time
property entrepreneur working for your
company and they and they did that they
made a couple of calls a week got a
little bit of rejection you'd fire them
so if you know if you take it serious as
a business you know so okay so you sold
those deals how much did that make I
made about just over £4,000 off those
deals and then I took on the one in
Cardiff ser comination and that was
actually just before I found those other
deals I took that one off from deal
sourer yeah um as soon as I took that
one on I found the other deals and then
the next week I took the one on in bath
and now I'm just going to you know stick
the C if I take on another three bed
within a week I've taken that one on I
got a two and a half month stay there
nice so that one's just sort of passive
now until the new year yeah so I'm
looking to take on another one in cardi
now and hopefully you get another stay
in there and just keep just keep the
ball rolling and also it's November
right now so the fact that you've got
money coming in November because people
think of servers to competation is just
tourists who are most of your guests uh
contractors professionals um at the
moment like the one in Cardiff is
there's five Amazon workers I'm assuming
there's like a delivery company yeah and
they've just put five workers in the
area just going to be so busy on
Christmas time yeah and they just going
to be so talk to me about the business
model then talk to explain to me because
there's a lot of people watching this
that might not even know what how you
control a property and how it all works
so what is the business model H what
value are you bringing to the
marketplace and how does it work so you
got landlords they have problems with
tenants sometimes they have tenants
coming in every six months and then
leave in they you know they trash the
properties um if they're not paying
bills they get in trouble getting the
tenants out they got take them to court
and there you know lengthy battles in
cold but as a company um we'll release
the property for normally 3 to 5 years
pay them guaranteed rent if I don't pay
rent they can just kick me straight out
of the property cuz you're a commercial
tenant a commercial tenant so no
arguments you haven't paid rent off you
go they get the property back you know
in the same condition that that I
receive the property or better sometimes
we will carry out many refs right like
for you know for example the shower
broke in Cardiff being a plumber myself
went down bought a new shower fitted the
new shower yeah that hasn't cost the
land load a penny you know if that was a
standard tenant that might have cost
them you know two 250 pound yeah which
could WIP A month's profit yeah so
they're having no un foren sort of um
bills to pay because I'm maintaining the
properties you know keeping them really
good standard CU at the end of day
that's my business and my property is
not in A1 condition not guest are going
to stay there so do you use the fact
that you're a plumber to your advantage
to get the deals does that help or do
you not mention it I haven't mentioned
it yet because I haven't needed to
really cuz when you just mentioned it
then it sounded really good yeah yeah
that's it even Bath Street you know if
if a property was a really good good
area and the landlord was will negotiate
a little bit on rent W happy fit new
bathrooms and right even boilers spit
the difference on the cost of the boiler
what type of properties are you renting
in are these um apartments or the houses
uh so you got two one bed Apartments uh
one three bed apartment that I've just
taken on a two- bed house now right so
if I'm a landlord in Cardiff and I own
an apartment yeah two bed apartment what
kind of rent typically are you paying
what kind of rent would they be able to
get a two bed apartment you look in
roughly about 12,200 okay and do these
have to be how close do they have to be
to the center like what's your sort of
catch area um the one bed I've got is
about half an hour way from the center
okay um it's got on street parking
outside yeah and the second three bed
I've taken on that one is literally like
a 10-minute walk into the center so the
one that's half an hour away has it got
stuff near it is there like hospitals is
there things popping or is it kind of
just in the middle of nowhere it well
it's say half hour it's a half hour walk
so it's probably like a know 10 8 10
minute drive sure so it's not too far
it's reasonably close yeah if I'm a
landlord and I've got a property a two
bear flat I could rent it for about
1,200 if I wanted to to a normal tenant
they'd be on a six-month as contract
there's risk that they may not pay rent
and then I'm going to have to evict them
there's risk that they might damage the
property there's risk that something
might just break and it's not their
fault and I have to pay for it the
boiler the this that the other what
you're offering is you're giving
guaranteed rent and you're saying look
I'll fix it for three years or however
long you're taking care of the small
maintenance so if there's little things
that are breaking you're paying and you
have to pay rent because it's not your
home so you don't have tenants rights y
so from a L's perspective it's quite an
easy sell I'm just wondering why you had
to make 180 calls
before you got a
yes I think some landlords not really
aware of what it is um they probably had
bad experiences and you know it's like
bad news travels faster than good news
so I think they hear in bad stories like
I hear a story myself where you know
company took on I think it was 100
properties Nationwide and then they just
deserted them and and left right um well
I think they assume that all companies
are out there to do that yeah where you
know really speaking this this is a
business that I'm looking to do long
term yeah so if I do one bad property
you know that's going to go back to the
agent the agent's going to say look
we're not working with him anymore so
it's obviously going to have a negative
effect on me you know the property at
the end of the day is my business so I'm
going to look after their property like
it's my own it's interesting though
because there's obviously things that
can go wrong the company could go bust
the company could not pay and then get
kicked out and then the landlord could
think never again but there's also
things that go wrong with normal tenants
and you don't see landlords generally
saying I'm never rent to a tenant again
cuz I had a bad experience this is the
nature of the business things can go
wrong wrong what would you do though if
you couldn't rent it out what would
happen or do are you confident that you
can because of the research and what
does that look like um what you do you
do diligence beforehand you check other
Calenders um check the demand in here
you could even be calling companies you
even call local agents to find out if
they've got any demand for short-term
stays and then you got your break clause
in place and so if you know you tried
everything it wasn't working you speak
to the landlord you know you could come
to some sort of agreement but obviously
the contract would have a know 3 six or
12 month break CLA right so if the
property was just absolutely tanking you
you'd exercise your breake clause and
have to say 6 months You' say look I'm
really sorry this isn't working out
here's your month's notice no hard
feelings and and then you've probably
maybe you've even lost a little bit of
money but you've learned something but
that would not happen if you done your
market research properly that's the
funny thing with Cardiff when he was
doing the market research like
everybody's calendar they looked empty I
thought why why is every calers looking
empty sometimes you got a gut feeling
you know it's going to work so you just
got to take our plan sometimes it's it's
strange cuz everything you teach us
about doing a du diligence checking the
nightly rates the occupancy rates you
look at C if you think it doesn't works
I'm not going to invest it if if you
went off just that is the way that we
teach it too strict are we too B on
braces possibly or is C if just a little
bit of
a I don't know I'm still sort of trying
to figure out why you look so bad when
you due diligence because obviously the
way you teach it is the safest way yeah
because I've gone in I've risked my
money and was willing to lose that money
if it didn't work how much would you
lose let's say you got hardly any
bookings it just barely covered the rent
and you had to walk away it's costing me
all heads in the one bed about just over
,000 a month plus OB Furniture which you
can take back out yeah deposits it's
more time and hassle then yeah because
you deposit you get back you your rent
that you're paying to the landlord I
mean unless you got zero bookings if
you're breaking even you're not going to
lose a massive amount of money but
you're going to it's going to be
frustrating yeah yeah like like my goal
at the beginning was just to get at
least 50% occupancy just to break even
so I'm learning as I'm sort of I'm
learning and earning and if you're like
as long as he wasn't losing money he was
happy and he went from being like 50% to
just like like bath had 100% occupancy
in the second month he was live and then
he had a one month booking in there and
now it's just sort of taking over like
towards Christmas he's going to be busy
yeah but Cardiff is just been long stay
after long stay and some lar requests
like the one the one bing card if I
think I could have filled it about four
times jeez so at that point then you
think right I need another property yes
so that's why I thought I'm go bigger to
see if a three bed Works know one bed
works but obviously on the bigger
properties you make more profit like the
three bed now I'm making well cuz it's
got a longterm stay about ,800 a month
um net profit on that one damn whereas
1,800 profit yeah that's a full-time
salary yeah just off one property and
how much do you have to put down um I pa
a s in for on that one so paid 3,000
souring fee sure ,500 rent and I think
it was, 1600 deposit so do you think
card if is a bit untapped I think so
it's it definitely works I know it works
it's proven why did you agree as well to
come and sharing your story because some
people might say I get people say this
to me all the time Sam why are you doing
YouTube videos telling everybody what
you're doing because you're just going
to create competition that's that that's
something that I get quite a lot and
I've got my own reasons namely I don't
believe in competition I believe in
collaboration but what was the reason
that you agreed to come and sort of
share and answer all these questions
about what you're doing in car just to
share and give back because at the
beginning had so much help like if if
people had to share the knowledge with
me I wouldn't have the longterm stage
like me speaking to Adam H he shared
loads of tips I speak a lot with the
twins um Lou helped me LGE with the Evo
like OB gav Mitch gav has helped me LGE
with the Evo yeah and these are all
people that are on the academy they've
done winners on a Wednesday like had a
great few tips off of harison cek of
Teri you know everybody's helped me so
then you just pass our knowledge on to
to the new sort of Academy members it's
just it's just we passing it on and and
helping each other up basically and it's
a much better way to be isn't it if
everyone's pulling each other up you
know the story you've probably heard me
mention it before but it's a story about
five crabs in a bucket yeah and and and
and every time one of the crabs goes to
get out the bucket the other four pull
it down because they don't want that one
to escape they want to escape but then
because they're all pulling each other
down they all die in the bucket a lot of
environments are like that in in in work
corporate everyone's pulling each other
down 100% whereas what we've created
with the academy is a community where
everybody's pulling everybody up yeah
and everybody gets to the top and
there's no it's not about competition to
collaborating like let's say there might
be a bunch of people that say I want to
get into ciff now but then you end up
partnering or or selling deals to the
people that you put Cardiff on the map
for yeah well I it like I took on the
three bed and there was another two
apartments in the same block yeah so I
worked with the deal sourcer they taken
my deal off and sold two deals to
another two investors from the academy
wow and I've helped them get up and run
in and one of them's got a long-term
stay um straight away and the other one
I think's got a one or two week booking
he's like nice how important is Network
oh it's everything if you don't know
something somebody in your network will
like you can go on the academy group
chat you can type any question you want
about property or not even about
property about most things in general
you can type something and somebody will
know the answer yeah it's just it's
unbelievable yeah I think I think
Network's important I think having a
strong team and having peers around you
trying to be successful in anything any
new Avenue when you've not got people
around you doing the same thing it's
it's lonely and it's tough and it's hard
100% when you see other people doing it
before you you just sort of following
the footsteps like like Instagram now
I'm doing you know Instagram reals and
things like that well that that's not me
when I first started I was like a you
know my friends going to rip me anyone
and I like but I thought you know other
people are doing it they successful so
I'm just going to follow any footsteps
yeah and and see how it goes and to be
fair all my friends have been quite
supportive none of them have uh have
ripped me down so that's good you
mentioned as well that um part of the
reason for wanting to get into property
was your mom yeah is that right yeah
like um when they were early 20s uh my
parents built their own house um to like
total bill cost and everything was
55,000 and the property is now worth
just under 400,000 so I I've seen with
my own eyes yeah how you know property
can sort of give you security yeah um
cuz few years later my father got
diagnosed with um the brain tumor um he
sad he passed away 15 years after that
and he always said to my mother you've
always got the house so like my mother's
on her own now she's fostered children
for the last 10 years and it's know it's
quite a big property and it's allowed
her to Foster the children give them a
better life and now she's looking to
downsize and she's got all that equity
in the property so she can buy a
property I'm hoping that I can help her
invest the rest of the money um to
create sort of Financial Freedom for my
mother as well yeah so you know I've
seen with my own eyes what property can
give you in the form of sort of
stability as well in yeah that's yeah
that's important and I think that
property ultimately we know over time it
doubles on average I did I recently was
looking at the stats I went back over a
hundred years and pretty much
consistently every 10 years it doubled
in value and it's just like and people
are saying oh but it's not going to be
the next 10 well they said that 10 years
ago and they said that 10 years ago
repeats itself it yeah and and and
having the skills to be able to make
money in property you can help family
and you can work with people that have
got Equity so um what would you say is
the uh the hardest bit about being a
property entrepreneur at the moment for
me is it's time um cuz I got two young
children and I feel like I'm giving up
time with my children at the moment to
invest into this but I know it's for the
for a greater cause if you know what I
mean so I'm looking to for the next year
or two now put everything I can into
this you know into doing property get
financially free hopefully sort of
systemize my Plum and heating business
which is going to give me more time you
know back with my family so sacrificing
a bit of time now to gain a lot more
time in the future yeah and those are
skills hopefully I can pass on to my
children and then you know that's just
going to go on for Generations and
general you yeah but the kind of money
that you're making from your rent to
rent properties like honestly like 1,800
on one property and then you've got the
others that that's enough money for most
people to just say I'm just going to put
my feet up and I'm going to retire right
now um you're not you're continuing to
build you've got kids and you want to
you want to leave a legacy what's the
strongest reason for your drive right
now then I think it's just having that
freedom it's not so much money and I'm
quite happy with the lifestyle I've got
I don't want any more you know s
materialistic things I just want more
time I want everything I've got but
without spending my time to get it
basically I know some and that's
Financial Freedom yeah some people might
think oh that's that's lazy you know you
should be working but I'm working harder
now than I've ever worked before I've
got the property and the plumbing
obviously with the winter with the
plumbing heating it's just gone crazy so
I'm just working every hour Under the
Sun at the moment yeah but I know it's
it's for Freedom you know in the future
it's not just for money yeah um which
obviously is is a greater goal than just
money what does freedom mean to you then
go on holidays a couple of times a year
with the family work work when I want to
not because I have to not worrying about
bills going out just just basically
living the life I'm living now you know
we go on holidays and things now but I'm
spending a lot of my time working you
know I'm working till late in the night
sometimes doing quotes sending invoices
speaking to customers and it's just a
lot of stress so if I can get the
lifestyle I've got now but without
having to put the hours and hours in and
stress that's you know that that's a
dream for me really how's life changed
then over the last sort of six 12 months
it's just gone
mental just is crazy um there's just not
a spare hour between running pluming
heat in and then doing everything with
with the property sideway like at the
moment my living room has got four
mattresses in the middle of the living
room your wife's quit work now though
yeah so yeah how does she feel about
that yeah I think she's uh she's quite
excited I think to to get involved now
you obviously she's been helping me
furnish the properties and things but
you know start looking to get on the
systems now like on a Vivo and just get
it sort of up on the prop side of the
business then where does most of your
time go is your time going going in
finding new deals and wanting to grow or
is it managing the properties that
you've got um it does spend a lot of
time managing the properties with the
fullterm know the long-term stays um
bath is a bit more sort of intensive
because it's like two nights two nights
it's I did have a one month staying
there but that's come to an end now so
it's back you know it's back being like
two three nights at a time so a lot of
communication with guests with things
like that um and the cleaner but yeah
it's just things in general making sure
payments are coming in and then
Furnishing the properties is quite time
intensive yeah but that's again that's
something that you do once yeah as you
grow when you take on a new property how
how many hours would you say on the
property business you're working right
now a week and what's the split what's
the breakdown at that time um maybe an
hour a day an hour a day on the whole
property business yeah I think so I
normally get home about I know 6:00 so
your most your work then is on your
plumbing business yeah so that's where
majority of the work is but you don't
want to quit that just yet because
you're still making decent money doing
it yeah I said I need to try do you make
more money on the property business or
on the plumbing business right now last
month probably property business hold on
a minute hang on a minute bro so you're
working an hour a day on the property
business sounds but the property
business is making more than the
plumbing business how many hours are you
working on the plumbing business way too
many um well 60 hours a week H what how
do you make sense of that it's the first
time I thought about it did do you think
you might potentially need to do
property fulltime yeah
possibly and that's not including the
sourcing and stuff that's just the rent
to rents bro that's pretty pretty
amazing uh what's more passive oh
proberbly weren't you on holiday
recently as well tell me that story yeah
so we went away with my family on a two
we holid day and while I was there
obviously money was being transferred
into my account from previous days yeah
and then he was receiving bookings and
obious a guest in the apartment at the
time and I think I calculated it was
like a received £2,800 with the bookings
actually into my account it was like
£3,200 with transferred in yeah and then
while I was away those two weeks they
generated another like 3,000 worth of of
income and you were on holiday yeah and
I was just like going back to him we got
another book in and man you're still a
bit early into the J you're eight months
in right but like I reckon in a year's
time bro yeah can you imagine what would
be your biggest piece of advice for
someone starting out that wants to be
able to make more money in an hour a day
then they do on their full-time business
or their full-time job what would be
your tips to starting out uh just just
put the work in you got to put the time
in I think you can't expect to just join
join up in the academy and everything
just land on your lap y the knowledge is
there the network is there you know your
power team everything is there for you
but you've got to put in the work if
you're not willing to put in the work
and and have that you know that work
work ethic you just you know you're
gonna fail it doesn't matter what you do
who's in front of you if you're not
willing to work you are going to fail
but if you are willing to work you've
got everything at your fingertips yeah
to help you succeed just talk a bit talk
a little bit about the academy what you
get and how and how it's helped you it's
just unbelievable I you went to the one
pong course first yeah then joined up to
the Advanced Training um I sort of knew
in my mind that I was going to join up
the academy because once that's just the
type person I am once I'm in something
that's it I'm in you know full on with
it my mother actually said to me before
I came for the second or training like
when you go up now don't go spending no
more money I think she was convinced it
was like a scam and just like a a
pyramid sort of system so I went up she
signed up to the academy sped my wife
first actually and she said look you
know if you think you can do it just
just go for it and that was all I needed
basically and just joined the academy
and having Lu back you know it's
unbelievable the network like I got
people all over the country you know
friends like Jordan from Swansea for
Aran sake didn't know Jordan before the
academy and I I speak to him every day
basically he's heavily into BR OB I've
gone into the you know the Renta mod so
we just passing things back and forth
working with each other um I'm actually
working on a project with the rail from
the academy at the moment she's doing a
br in Bend so I'm actually doing the
pluming heat in there nice um so it's
it's just opened up doors that that
wouldn't have been possible without
joining the academy basically yeah um
you know there's people there to help
you give you advice and it's just
unbelievable um what's your wife sort of
saying then is she like buzzing right
now I think she's excited to get
involved now and I obviously excited for
it to be a part of as well so we can and
go on the journey together are you
planning on doing bio refurbish Finance
like flips and brrs in Cardiff um where
they from in the r there um properties
are really cheap it's a great area for
brrs is a university about 20 minutes
away so I may jump into like BR hore the
rules are all a bit different aren't
they in Wales I don't know if you know
about you probably do because you're
from Wales but they've um they've
scrapped ests haven't they a contracts
and they've got a whole new different
type of tency so if you're investing in
in Wales I mean to be honest even in
England you go from Council to council
and the rules are different you might
have article four in an area or you
might have licensing rules might be
different yeah so it's really important
to make sure that you go over this is
what part of what we do on on the
obviously on the Advanced Training which
is going over the rules the regulations
making sure people are fully aware of
them which I think is important because
it's all good making money but you want
to be making sure that you're also doing
everything absolutely koser yeah that's
it but it's like like local to me know
they've upgraded all the train lines so
so every like 10 minutes there going to
be trains going straight into Cardiff
nice um like I think pretty much the
whole of Wales it's it's difficult to
get any sort of solid information on it
but I spoke to a guy in my L gr with
planning um he said basically you need
planning there is no permitted
development rights within Wales you need
planning for everything but like within
those like the article 4 area if you
want to call it there's of conservation
areas but there's a nice area by me you
can come just outside of that and
basically it's just he said that if you
want to hit J more there's no reason why
they wouldn't allow H more or an sa
because you know Wales looking to
promote o tourism um basically said
99.9% guaranteed to get you know sort of
planning nice and that's again local
contacts are important yeah and and just
studying one of my Plumbing customers
yeah was it one of your plumbing
customers and that's why I think as well
it makes sense to not be super scaton
it's easy when you first start in
property to be looking at properties in
um you know in London and Birmingham and
Liverpool and grim be and you just
running around but I think it's really
important to Just Master your area and
really understand the market and the
rules of an area what's next then for
you Ian what's the plan over the next
eight months you you've killed it over
the last over the last eight you
basically financially free making
thousands of pounds every month almost
passive coming in what's next so my plan
I want to hit that 10K month Target um
from like so like not so much deal
selling because deal selling I find is
quite intense time wise constantly back
and forth investors yeah like it's great
to make sort of quick cash flow but my
main goal is to get sort of cash flow in
like rent to SAS I want to get up to
£10,000 a month from that and then I'm
going to look to start buying properties
and then replacing the rent to SAS as
they come to the end of the contracts
with my own sort of assets yes to create
that t cash flow that's great what a
great plan that's the plan so going from
a plumber making you know okay living
making a decent living but then
transitioning into being a property
entrepreneur and then from that a
property owner and investor um it's a
great plan and you must be very proud of
yourself I don't know do you ever just
pinch yourself or look back when you see
the money coming in and just damn it's
when I sit down actually look at the
figures I think you know I'm doing it
it's actually working yeah um like
obviously to have a to be asked to come
on winners on a Wednesday that's a
massive Milestone and like I said you
when you first asked it was like oh no I
don't feel ready but then when I thought
about I thought hang on now you've come
from there to where you are now you are
actually doing it and it's just it's
just mindblowing it's yeah said you got
to pinches sometimes it's awesome well
you should be really proud what would
you say would be your number one piece
of advice to people listening to this
before we wrap up just guessing mentors
if you're thinking about getting into
property don't just think there's one
strategy the BR strategy there's so many
different ways to earn money in property
get involved just get a mentors even
even if you're not going to pay for
courses just speak to people in your
local area go to networking events and
just get knowledge off people around you
to help you when Journey well the crash
course is a pound yeah which is where it
all started for you and we have a slogan
which is it all starts at the crash
course what was your experience when you
came to the crash course oh this is
unbelievable it's just great environment
to be in you know you give little tips
and things along the way and you just
know that that's the the route they want
to go down I know some people will go on
they might not the academy or they might
not go the Advanced Training but even
just that one pound you learn so much in
that one day that's probably enough just
to you know just to get the ball rolling
yeah it is it is what it is a crash
course what we got lose is one pound
yeah there we go well mate massive
respect well done and I look forward to
see you continuing to absolutely burn
thank very much and if you've not been
to the one pound property investors
crash course yet where I can DSE
everything there is to know about
property and push it all into a one day
seminar come and meet me let's spend the
day together I'll leave a link in the
description and I look forward to seeing
you smash it also in
property
[Music]